nous savons qu'il y a d'autres histoires à raconter,
mais nous n'avons jamais ressenti la pression
de les pousser là-bas jusqu'à ce que nous
sentions qu'il y a une belle histoire à raconter et
que nous avons quelque chose
qui sera à nouveau une entrée digne de
l'
univers de la conjuration.  J'aimerais que vous vous
asseyiez tous tranquillement et que vous fermiez les yeux
[Musique]
Je voulais vraiment que le pays trois
s'éloigne de la maison hantée
des deux premiers films de prestidigitation, cela
devrait être plus à un
tout autre niveau quelque chose que
nous n'avons jamais exploré  Avant, dans le
monde de la prestidigitation, nous voulions
garder notre nouvelle histoire ancrée dans la sensation
des films de prestidigitation,
mais nous voulions nous assurer que nous
racontions une toute nouvelle histoire et nous pensons que
l'histoire d'Arne Johnson
était quelque chose qui méritait vraiment un
examen beaucoup plus approfondi
car je  Je suis allé au bas des escaliers et
je suis allé ouvrir la porte.
Je ne me souviens de rien à partir de ce
moment-là. La prochaine chose que je sais, c'est que
j'étais dans une cellule de prison et j'ai dit ce qui se
passe ici
et ils disent que tu es accusé.
pour meurtre  j'ai dit de
quoi tu parles
[Musique]
le procès d'arne cheyenne johnson
c'était une
affaire de renommée internationale qui était la première fois
dans l'histoire du droit aux
états-unis que
cette possession démoniaque était utilisée comme
raison pour commettre un
homicide involontaire  pensez que vous serez en mesure
de prouver l'existence du diable devant un
tribunal la
vérité n'oblige personne à y
croire vous êtes dans une course très différente de celle
que vous avez faite dans d'autres
films de prestidigitation quel est l'intérêt d'une
suite  si vous ne pouvez pas
briller et sortir de l'histoire et dépasser
les films précédents, cela vous oblige simplement
à apporter
votre jeu un plus quand je travaillais avec
michael shoves sur la yorona
j'ai vu un cinéaste qui obtient vraiment ce
genre de films
c'est doux-amer pour moi  pour passer le
relais
et l'action, mais c'est bien d'avoir une nouvelle
vision
de l'endroit où nous pouvons prendre l'
univers de la prestidigitation, nous offrons quelque chose de très
spécial
avec ces films et je pense que c'est l'une
des raisons pour lesquelles les gens reviennent sans cesse
la dernière raison bien sûr est que les
gens aiment avoir peur je ne sais pas
si quelqu'un a
conçu ou créé de meilleures
séquences d'effarouchement que
james wan david sandberg gary dauberman
corn hardy john leonetti michael chavs les
gars nous faisons contra et trois ça
va être  génial, ce sont tous des gens
qui savent vraiment ce qu'ils font et
ils font un travail incroyable en
créant de nouvelles séquences effrayantes originales
, c'est vraiment ce que les gens
reviennent pour vous voir